hello everyone I welcome you to today's
psyomic session
IX is a bioinformatics and a data
science student Club it is an initiative
taken by the students associated with
bind biotech the goal of the Scio mix
Club is to help students learn about
bioinformatics research via group
sessions easy to take courses debates
and discussions
bioinformatics and its related domains
are vast and offer a great opportunity
for students of life science to forge
their own paths this club welcomes
students from all fields of life science
to come and meet together and learn from
each other the psyomix aims at
encouraging young minds to push their
critical thinking limits beyond the
school and college curriculum
we are excited to start the second
psyomix fall 2022 session today
the theme of the session revolves around
multi-ohomics data analysis and
bioinformatics
zionic sessions are aimed at bringing
together the network of expert Educators
and students from all around the globe
to learn from each other by interacting
And discussing the advances in the field
of bioinformatics
discussions will be highlighting the
challenges involved in the research
using computational tools for Big Data
analysis and opportunities in this
outgoing field along with its
applications
let me introduce myself to all of you my
name is ayushi notra and I am the
marketing associate and coordinator at
Pine biotech and the president of the
zionics club
I have completed my masters in systems
biology and bioinformatics and I have a
keen interest in applying bioinformatics
and systems biology approaches used to
analyze High throughput data here we
have provided you with the links of our
Telegram and our WhatsApp groups
along with the QR codes by joining the
student Club you will be able to broaden
your Horizon and get an opportunity to
explore collaborative project internship
career and also learn through virtual
sessions
you all must be curious to know certain
things during the initial stage of your
career
like how can you get noticed in the
community what are the challenges and
opportunities and where is
bioinformatics headed at
the answer to all the above queries is
to learn about critical skills needed in
Academia and Industry position
by seeing what others are doing and
hearing from leaders and participating
in Project driven education that has
demonstrable outcomes in learning and
placement
the main focus of psyomix Club is to
study about bioinformatics and data
science related fields such as
infectious disease microbes and
microbiome plant signs Neuroscience
Precision oncology and applications of
big data in biology to clear the
concepts of bioinformatics to gain
insights on how to use tools of
bioinformatics to learn how to apply
research in day-to-day life through
brainstorming sessions and to help
the group to enhance the critical
thinking capabilities and gaining
experience in data science skills
start your bioinformatics journey you
can come on and learn through the omics
logic learn portal
let me quickly show you what the omics
logic learn portal looks like
so this is the omics logic Clan portal
if you've already signed in you can
quickly go on to the courses tabs or the
programs tab to see what the omics logic
portal beholds for you and if you are a
new user you can just simply type
omixlogic.com on Google and go on to
this page and log in or maybe sign in
you can do so by using any of your
social media accounts which is your
Google Facebook Apple ID Orkut or
Twitter or maybe you can simply log sign
in using your email ID and password that
you set by going on to this create an
account option once you sign in it's
very important to for you to have a
updated profile for that you simply need
to click on your name
and you need to go on to this profile
section over here you need to put in
your profile photo a brief file and link
your social media accounts
and update your profile
so coming back to the session today
um
the omics logic platform also includes
certain free introductory courses for
you such as introduction to
bioinformatics and bytes and molecules
these are self-learning introductory
courseworks which are related to
bioinformatics omic studies like
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
epigenomics and space-omics and data
science that includes bioinformatics
using R and python
so the aim of this psyomix group is to
guide students on common queries that
you have by Logic start your career such
as
um you know and we do so by group
discussions such as we review report
writing based on self-assessed courses
we debate on brainstorming areas in
bioinformatics and data science we
perform presentations in research papers
we discuss and exchange ideas for
research project development we discuss
about how bioinformatic Industries is
different from Academia and how can
student Transit from Academia to
industry along with this we also discuss
about job and internship opportunities
for undergraduate and postgraduate
students how to build soft skill and
technical skills and and the interview
and CV guidance
so what will we learn today
we all have heard about MGs
but have you ever wondered what is the
Revolution and evolution of this
technique and why has this technique
become such as such an integral part of
the bio biological sciences
the growing part in reduced cost sparked
an enormous range of applications of NGS
thereby to understand about the
Revolution and evolution of this
technique today we have Dr Whip and
Singh with us
he will be talking about the evolution
and Revolution a perspective on 40 Years
of on DNA sequencing
Dr whippen Singh is a postdoctoral
fellow at ibens Paris he completed his
PhD from csir ccmb Hyderabad he has 10
years of teaching experience and
research experience in some of the best
private universities in India he has a
specialization in genome transposoned by
informatics and is proficient in various
languages such as Pearl python R and
Minix besides teaching and research we
had a very successful stint and
placement coordinator and the corporate
resource center and as admission
coordinator at the admissions he has
been instrumental in grooming students
through soft skill training sessions and
placement
and placing students in various biotech
and Allied companies
so thank you so much Dr vipin Singh for
joining with us today we hope that this
session will be full of learnings for
all the participants that are here once
again I would like to thank you for
joining in now I'm passing on the stage
to you sir thanks ayushi I hope I am
audible to you and we can start with the
presentation now yes sir your Audible
let me just share my screen and then we
can start right so share
and there you are so let me just open my
PPT here
so there you are on the should be
well you always have this problem of
opening multiple ppts and then you're
not sure which one is the correct one so
let me just take the other one this is
not the one yes
right so let me just start from the
front
all right so let's get started and I see
there are some 20 students around so we
will now start with the talk and the
talk is titled Evolution to Revolution a
perspective on 40 Years of DNA
sequencing so we are into the 48th or
41st year of DNA sequencing Technologies
it started way back in 1997 and then
1977 and then since then there has been
a continuous evolution of the sequencing
techniques nowadays you have four common
sequencing techniques one is Illumina
the other than torrent and then you also
have what is now coming up in a big way
is nanopore and packed by the sequencing
so we'll talk each of these as we begin
so we start with the historical
perspective and then we move on to what
are these techniques and how these are
being applied and how sequencing has
become the new microscopes it is
commonly same that sequencing is the new
microscope for everything that you need
to go forward first step is to do the
sequencing right so we'll start with the
talk now and we'll see how sequencing is
evolved and how it is helping us do
better science and do a more
Comprehensive Science than we had done
earlier right so here you are
so we'll look at the basic concept in
sequencing and in the store so we can
text
then we'll look for why there was a need
for Next Generation frequencing
techniques in 2001 will be our
breakpoint here then we'll talk of the
Contemporary sequencing techniques we'll
talk of short rate and long lead
sequences we'll talk about filter
terminal sequencing we'll talk of ion
torrent nanopore sequencing and we'll
also talk of real-time single molecule
real-time sequencing then we'll talk of
applications and data analysis tips in
ngis and remember and regulations you
can even talk can be endless you know
there are so much to tell that it can be
endless and it is a field that is very
quickly evolving so every time I give
this talk there is a new technique that
is available that has to be incorporated
and the previous technique that has
become obsolete so that has to be taken
off here so this is how we go about and
then of course there are certain
prerequisites to induce data analysis so
the students are expected to know a bit
of Linux environment a better
programming so we'll discuss that as
well because I'm sure most of you would
go into research and if you go into
research sequencing is something that
you cannot avoid right it's like your
PCI and wet lab sequencing data analysis
is now the next thing and you definitely
would come across at some step of your
research you would have some sequencing
data to analyze so therefore some of the
prerequisites that are important we'll
discuss those as well
so let's uh look into history this is
February 2001 and if you see here this
is President Bill Clinton then the
president of America's and he is
basically inaugurating the event that is
the launch or the basically the
announcement of the completion of the
human genome sequencing project uh and
you can see in the background it says
decoding The Book of Life a milestone
for Humanity and the people responsible
for this are these two people this one
in front is Craig winter who forms
cellular genomics and and published a
paper in science with their own with the
human genome sequence and this one here
is Francis Collins he was the leader of
the Human Genome Project the publicly
funded project and this again the paper
came in nature so the two most uh
significant journals in in science as
such right so I'm sure you would have
heard the name so let's get back to the
basics now so what actually is meant by
sequencing right so sequencing means
that you are looking at the order of
nucleotides in in nucleic acid molecule
right so let me just shift this bar here
that is
all right this one is fine I need to
shift this part yeah okay so
here you are so
today so what is sequence rinsinger is
basically to uh determine the
let me just close this message here so
determine the order of nucleotides in a
nucleic acid you know there are four
nucleotides a t g and c and basically
the order in which they appear results
in a certain sort of code that can allow
for for coding a protein for encoding a
site where a Putin can come and bind for
transcription Factor binding and so on
so forth automatic modification so
therefore frequencing becomes important
right so the question is then uh why do
you
and what the specifically the sequencing
that we're looking at is what is known
as The genome sequencing what is the
genome I'm sure you would know genome is
one full complement of genetic material
in an organism or a cell and sequencing
genomes is challenging even today and it
was much more challenging when we
started sequencing the human genome and
we'll come to it why it is so
challenging we'll come to it in the next
few slides
so here you are what is the the idea of
sequencing a genome why do you want to
sequence genomes well the first thing is
you know that DNA is the blueprint all
of you know about the central dogma so
DNA is our genetic code and then it gets
transferred into RNA which then gets
transcribed into translated into protein
protein is the workforce so therefore we
want to know what is there at the basal
levels in genetic code then we also want
to look at how what are the different
types of variations that can exist
within these species or between two
species and more importantly the idea of
sequencing the human genome was to
basically try and identify variations or
the changes in this sequence of between
two individuals that can result in
disease so you wanted to we wanted to
associate a certain mutation to a
certain disease or certain variation to
a certain disease so therefore the major
the major objective of sequencing the
human genome was for biomedical
applications and I'll give you towards
the end of the talk I'll give you an
example of how that can be effective
right
so I told you genome sequencing is
complex why is it complex because you
know most of the sequencing Technologies
today rely on synthesizing a
complementary DNS front using DNA
polymerase
and then you basically you know as the
network types get added you do a
real-time identification of which
network type got added and that allows
you to basically know what is the order
of nucleotides on the template snap so
here you are the problem is that we
still do not have an environment that
can directly sequence a large piece of
DNA while there has been progress and
we'll talk of it as we move along but we
still do not have let's say you're
trying to sequence chromosome one so
there is no enzyme even today which can
invit row directly replicate chromosome
one from one into the other end so
therefore if you want to sequence this
large DNA molecule you first have to
break it into smaller pieces right which
are amenable to sequencing as in when
you do a complementary uh you know and
rhyme when you do a complementary
extension uh you should be able to reach
the end of that fragment so here you are
you break it into smaller fragments a b
c d and e and you get the sequence of
individual parts and now the challenge
is to rearrange it back in the order it
is appearing in the original genome so
that is is the process that is known as
assembly so if you look at a typical
genome assembly genome sequencing
project there are three main parts one
is to create a genomic library that is
to predictive genomic DNA into smaller
pieces
second is to sequence these individual
pieces and then the third is to assemble
them back into the original order in
which they were in The genome which is
called the assembly and this was where
the major problem is and you know it
takes time and it is most resource
intensive and also it is this is the
place where you can go wrong right so
therefore uh genome sequencing even
today is complex although now it has
become a lot easier because we are now
in there of long range sequences and
towards the end of the talk I'll show
you that it is only now in 2022 April 24
we have the first complete assembly of a
human genome from telomere to telomere
from one end of the chromosome to the
other end of the chromosome without any
gaps I'm sure you would have read that
paper it has come in April 2022 right so
here you are so now once you have the
sequence you get it back and arrange it
in the order the it would appear in the
genome and finally get your genome
sequence We are following everyone
yes sir we're following okay so then we
move on and we talk more about it right
so here you are ah this got stuck all
right so let's talk about some basic
conception sequencing first before we
move on to sequencing Technologies so
here you are one of the conception
sequencing is what is known as read
length so here is an image that I
clicked when I was in Paris I'm also
photographer by Hobby so this is your
Eiffel Tower taken from shuttle in Paris
a beautiful evening so what does the
challenge that I'm giving you is that
I'm splitting this picture into four
parts
nine parts and 56 parts and then you
have to rearrange it together back into
the original picture so which of these
would be the most difficult to rearrange
anyone
the last one
the last one okay so it is very clear
because it has a lot more parts and
therefore there can always be a
confusion between you know this one and
this one these are roughly the same
shade so I could put this one here and
this one here and then it changes the
composition of my picture and I do not
get the exact replica of what I've
originally began with right so in in
analogy you can say that this is a long
read frequencer where the the genome
that you want to sequence have been
broken into larger pieces this is an
intermediate read sequencer for example
this anger sequencer 900 base pairs uh
this one is let's say nanopore or back
biosequencer and this one is Illumina
sequencer where you have fragments are
the smallest 150 bases to begin with
right so this is uh the concept of read
length the longer the read length the
more easy it is to assemble the genome
correctly the shorter the read length
the more the problems right
so this is your genomic Library this is
a large fragment Library this is
intermediate tweet Library this is your
short read library right
so read length the maximum sequence
length that can be obtained in one
sequencing reaction
this is specific to each sequencing
technique so if you're using Illumina
you get around 150 bases if you're using
ion torrent you get around 100 bases if
you are using nanopore you can on an
average get 10 KB sequence and if you're
using map pack bio again or smrt single
molecule real-time sequencing we'll talk
of these as we go into details again you
can get very easily 10 KB to 30 KB
sequences very easily so therefore the
assembly becomes a lot easier so read
length is critical here's a critical
parameter for completeness and accuracy
of the genome sequence more so in repeat
regenomes and why this is important is
because if you're sequencing the human
genome then the human genome has more
than 50 repeat content so if you rely
only on unique overlaps you will not be
able to assemble the genome together and
we'll talk of this in more details as
people hold on
so here you are so what you do is you
basically have your sequences these are
your short read sequences you put them
together align it to a reference for
example let's say so this is your
chromosome 5 and we are looking at
positions on chromosome 5 position 500
and we're looking also at position
chromosome 5 position 5000. so what you
have done is this is your reference
genome to which you're aligning your
short reads right
so there is a concept of what is known
as depth or coverage in sequencing so
what is exactly the depth of temperature
sequencing if you're looking at an
individual position here let's say we're
looking at chromosome 5 position 500
then the number of reads that overlap
this position here so that each one is
150 basis but this position you have one
two three four five six seven and eight
reads that map to this position so the
coverage for this position is 8x
likewise for this position chromosome 5
position 5000 the coverage is 2X and
then you see there is a position here
where there is no reads mapping so this
would be a gap you will not be able to
uh have any coverage here right so this
is uh one good idea one idea of one
basic concept in sequencing is of
coverage with Next Generation
frequencing you get really high coverage
with Sanger sequencing the maximum you
could get was 30X mostly you got was 10x
with Next Generation 3 pencing where you
can do massively parallel sequencing you
get very easily a coverage of one red X
you can go on to as much X as you want
depending on how much money you have in
your project right so and the other idea
also is what you do is now that you have
your reads aligned up here you can see
this is overlapping with this then this
one is overlapping with this overlaps
with this overlaps with this so you can
connect all reads that overlap with each
other and
form what is known as a Quantic till the
point you get your overlap so here you
are this is what you're doing sorry so
this is what is your quantity from here
until here you have overlapping reads
you put them together you already have a
reference so you're not so mindful of
the Beats you put them together into one
contig this region where there is no
read map you cannot explain it any
further now you come to the second
cluster of reads these are again
overlapping with each other you can put
them together as a second contact so
this is your content too right and in
between you have what is known as a gap
and this Gap is because there is no read
in your library that maps to this
reading now also how to increase the
coverage so coverage if you look at the
basic formula is small n into small L
small L is the length of the individual
read that you get individual sequence
that you get the suspects as well the
platform I told you Illumina will give
you 150 and torrent will give you 100
and nanopore and pack by will give you
around let's say 10 KB to 30 KB capital
L is the length of your genome which is
also affects depending on which organism
you're looking at so the only thing you
can change here is the n the more Rich
your library is the more repetitive your
library is the higher the coverage you
will get right so that is important
again coverage is critical and variation
and epigenetic Analysis higher the
coverage the more statistical power and
confidence in the analysis so basically
the idea is that the more coverage you
have this position you are more
confident that the nucleotide that
you've called here is actually the
correct nucleotide right so this is one
idea of coverage
then when you assemble genomes there is
also an idea of what is known as n50
right what is in 50 so let's say you
have this context of varying sizes in
your uh once you assemble your genome
you have these so you have a hundred
kilobase uh quantity the largest one the
70 60 50 50 40 and 50. so you arrange
your context in decreasing order of
their length and then what you're
looking for is you know the length of
your assembly here the cumulative length
of assembly is 400 kilobases so now what
you're doing is you're looking at the
read list that gives you roughly that
gives you 50 of your read length so 50
over assembly length so if your assembly
is 400 kilobases you are looking for you
keep adding the length of contigues here
till the time you read you read a sum
that is equal into
200 KB or more right so and then the
quantity that corresponds to that
basically is your n50 so in this case
100 plus 7170 170 plus 6230 so 60 KB is
your n50 value and so this is also an
indicator of how good your assemble is
the larger the value of the N15 which
means the larger the side of the
quantity at 1050 the more correct your
assembly is likely to be the lesser the
gaps are going to be right so that is
again uh one of the concepts in
sequencing you're following class
everyone
but then we move on and we talk more
about the
next Concepts
so this is your n50 n50 equals to 60
here then we move on and we talk of so
what you can also do is you could
basically once you have your library you
could have larger fragments that you
could sequence only from one end or you
could sequence from both ends so this
one here what I show you
in the library that is sequenced only at
one end so let's say you're using
Illumina so this could be your 400 basis
but whatever sequencing only 150 bases
from one end right and then you align it
to a reference genome so you you read
here gets aligned uniquely at some
places and one of these orange reads
gets aligned at two different places so
now you know that your orange lead is
likely to be repeat two or more you know
so if it is a repeat let's say it is
coming from an Aloo repeat so Aloo
repeats are 1.5 million copies in the
human genome so this sequence which is
coming from an algorithm it will go to
1.5 million places in your alignment
right so this is one idea then so and
what is the basic thing that I'm telling
you is that you had your fragment but
you have only sequence it from one end
the other thing that you can do is you
have your fragment and you could
sequence it from both ends so while the
sequence is larger 400 bases you have
the first 150 basis from one end and the
other 150 basis from the other end
together and now when you read when you
align read one and read two on to the
creation on to the reference genome here
what you see is that they are separated
by 700 bases here they were separated by
400 bases in your original genome that
you have taken from so which means that
this indicates that there is a
there is a insertion in the reference
genome that you do not have and this
could possibly be your repeat insertion
letter and I would beat again right so
this is uh when you do a paired and read
sequencing you could also Identify some
structural variations in your genome
right including your repeat insertion
polymorphisms or small insertions or
deletions so that is also one idea in
sequencing you could do single end
sequencing or you could do a parent
sequencing and these May again be
helpful in assembly now we come to
assembly complications when you have
repeated so for example here the red one
is a repeated right so what you do is
you have your repeats or you have your
sequences here these are individual
reads A B C D and E so you have when you
compare the three prime end of a you
have a unicorn five Prime end of C so
you know C follows a now when you
compare the three prime end of C it has
the same match with the five Prime end
of B with the five Prime end of e with
the five element of f so now now you are
stuck you are not sure which of these
fragments is next to C so this is one
major problem with short reads where you
cannot really uh very comfortably do a
dinovo sequencing and therefore most of
the times when you have a short read you
do a reference based assembly with long
read sequencer there is an advantage
that you because you have long reads
some of these reads would span over the
repeated and have a unique end that
would allow you to assemble them dinovo
without the need of a reference right so
that is again some something that is
advantages will Long Reach frequencies
so here we are we are talking of these
so we are talking of Sanger sequencer
then this is the Illumina the original
version right then you have the ion
torrent machine then you have nanopore
and you can see the size comparison
nanopore is mostly of size of a large
pen drive right and it could be held in
hand and that is the the Plus or or
Advantage with nanopore we'll talk of it
in more details as we go along then you
have the chromaton this is the multiple
assembly of nanoporce and then this is
your pack biosequencer so this is the
evolution of sequencing techniques we're
talking about in between there have been
many other techniques that have come and
gone for example pyro sequencing is
obsolete now likewise solid sequencer is
obsolete now so there has been evolution
in the last 20 years we have moved from
first generation to Second Generation to
the third generation which you can say
but sequencing began with spread
sandwich right and fretzanger got Nobel
Prize twice one was for uh for
identifying the insulin sequence and the
second was for developing a technique
for for the DNA sequence so Sanger
sequencing as you popularly know and the
other person here is Walter Gilbert who
holds a developed a method of sequencing
the DNA which was not so successful
because it could not be automated so
this does here
so even today most of the sequencing
techniques rely on polymerase so what
happens is you have a template that you
want to sequence here you add an adapter
to it so that you you can add a
complementary primer here and once you
add the complemented primer you give DNA
polymerase and DNA polymerase as it
extends the nucleotides you are able to
in some manner identify which nucleotide
got added and that allows you to
basically decipher the sequence on the
template because of the base
complementarity rule right so here you
are this is how you do it so basically
the most of the techniques rely on
polymerase based sequencing you have a
primer of DNA of length n so this is the
red fragment is represented the DNA also
and then you give a dntp and you give
the end polar DNA polymerase the primer
gets extended by one nucleotide at a
time and it also releases a
pyrophosphate and then h plus ion and
these are important because in some
cases you identify by which nucleotide
got added in other cases you identify by
whether the Pyro phosphate released or
not especially in pyrosequencing this
was the case and in other cases like
iron torrent you identify the signal of
incorporation based on whether the pH of
the medium changed or not because there
will be hydrogen and release if the
incorporation of the nucleotide takes
place so therefore each of these has its
own importance but most commonly what he
uses a fluorescent
dntp which is differentially colored
which means atg and C are all
differently colored and that allows for
basically you know
identification of which nucleotide got
Incorporated in real time
so we come to First the standard
sequencing very quickly we'll go through
this so standard sequencing was a very
smart way of sequencing the DNA okay um
they use the ntps and alongside they've
also use what is known as DD Integrity
or die deoxy nucleotide triphosphate so
these would not have a three plank wedge
and because the three prime weight is
absent then once a ddntp gets
Incorporated further extension does not
happen so here you are you have your
primer and your extending so you the the
polymerase will have a choice of adding
a normal timing or a radial thymine a
product of the thymine gets added no
further extension happens however in
cases where you have
a normal timing it moves to the second
position again it has an option of
adding a die deoxy Adeline or a normal
adenine if a dry deoxy I didn't get
started you will not get for that
extension so likewise you keep doing on
these positions and what to end up is if
you see here
what you end up with is a series of
fragments that differ from each other by
one nucleotide and they have a color
take tag at the last nucleotide that is
there and because each of these four
little types have a different color you
are able to identify what is the last
nucleotide in this particular fragment
so what you do next is you separate them
out on a gel and the gel that we use
here is capital electroprocessors and
then of course you also observe what is
the nucleotide passing through at the
point of observation based on the color
you have a laser that detects which
nuclear with what is the color here and
that allows you to translate it into a
language of nucleotides and that is how
you get your final sequence so this is
your sequence here if you see what you
get is the chromatogram and with
corresponds to bands and these can then
be you know translated into actual
nucleotides so automated standard
sequencing was a smart move because it
used differentially labeled fluorescent
DD ntps facilitates resolution of all
fragments in a single Lane instead of
code for each sample so before using a
differentially labeled ddntps the only
level available was what is known as the
radio label and radio level would
produce black color so therefore for one
sample you have to do four different
reactions with DD and differentiable
dntps ddntps it became easy for one
sample you have only one lane and that
became easy differential labeling also
increases the read length as the bands
can be allowed to flow out of the gel
post detection so in this case you could
not allow the drill to the bands to flow
out of the gel here in this case you
have a detection Point here one should
the band has been detected and the color
is known you know which nucleotide it
corresponds to you can allow it to pass
through and allow the other bands to get
resolved right
then you use capillary electrophoresis
and higher parallelism of magnitude
examples in one run and the sequence
outputed in the form of a chromatogram
so this is typically a chromatogram that
you see here
and you had automated slanger sequencer
and automated triangle sequences were
while they were you know
very effective when sequencing the human
genome so the major achievements of
these triangle sequencing in 1995 we
were able to save two to sequence the
first free living organism that is
female pile of influenza the 1993
frequenced yeast in 2000 with sequence
of Law and arabidopsis these are both
model organisms I'm sure you know draw
supplies for Animals there's also plants
and then in 2001 the crowning Glory of
Sanger sequencing was that we could
sequence the human genome however the
problem was that it had taken us 10
years to sequence the human genome also
because there was no reference available
earlier and then of course what was more
important was that besides 10 years it
had taken us 3.2 billion dollars to
sequence the first human genome which
was a problem if if a genome was to be
sequential 3.2 billion dollars we are
not anywhere close to our idea of
personalized medicine right so therefore
there was a grand challenge that was
launched and that resulted in the second
duration of frequencing techniques and
uh developed to sequence and assemble
the whole genome using a reference speed
and cost effective was what was
important the idea was to develop a
sequencing technique that would sequence
the human genome around thousand dollars
right and very recently we have come
very closely sequencing with you know
one thousand dollars So based on these
techniques and the the evolution of
sequencing techniques you now have three
generational sequences one is the
classical the first generation we've
talked of fanger method then you have
power sequencing virtual Terminator
sequencing and solid both parasquencing
and solid are now obsolete but this one
here by Illumina virtual Terminator
sequencing is the market leader even
today right and then of course you move
on to the third generation this is 2008
and evolving and you have Nano nanopore
and torrent and single real time
sequencing which are now reading the
market Illumina of course is the one
that leads the market today 80 of the
market by alumina but the long range
frequencies are fast cutting up ahead so
here you are if you look at the
comparison the effect now the effort
have been into including the read length
and if you see here again uh the Pyro
sequencing or the polymerase based
sequencing solexa was polymerase
sequencing as well this is the Illumina
and solid was like SB sequencing now
these are obsolete aluminized what
continues so if you look at the
Contemporary sequencing technologies
that are available in the market today
you you can classify them into two
different categories one is what is
known as the short read secret build and
the other is what is known as the long
lead frequences and as the name
indicates shot it the content will have
short read length and therefore the
assembly would be a bit of a problem
long read frequences will have longer
read length the assembly will not be a
problem but there could be problems in
the actual accuracy so what people now
do is to go for Long Reach frequencies
to ensure that they correct the correct
they get the correct assembly and
basically couple it with short it will
convert so that the individual positions
that they're wanting to look at
variations those are
so you have a hybrid you know
methodology or or basically synergize
long read or short read to get correct
assembly and also the Precision in terms
of the individual variation points that
you're looking at you follow class
everyone
yes sir
okay good
so then we move on and we talk a bit
about common features of second
generation sequencing so here you are
Library preparation random fragmentation
starting DNA edition of custom linkers
this is common to all of the second
generation whether it is power
sequencing or Illumina
or solid then you have the library
amplification
so the individual fragments that we
generate they have to be Amplified in a
local very closed area that is basically
called a cluster and there are two types
of PCR that you do here one is called
the bridge PCR another is called the
emergent PCR Bridge PCR works for
Illumina and the immersion PCR works for
power sequencing for solid and for ION
torrent trying and then uh next what is
important is that all of these
techniques give you a direct detection
as the nucleotide gets Incorporated you
have an idea of which nipple type got
Incorporated so this is a real time
sequencing and the other important
feature is and where it is course over
single sequencing is what is known as
the massively parallel sequencing
because these are high throughput
techniques you have millions to billions
of reads coming out from one run of the
machine so therefore the you know the
short read is compensated by the actual
output that is very huge in contrast to
capillary sequences that will be Sanger
sequencing the read lengths are shorted
here right so I have already told you
illuminum will give you 150 basis and
your
iron torrent will give you around 100
bases right and power sequencing could
give you around 400 basis but now it is
decommissioned not for not in use
anymore
so first we talk of Illumina or the
basic sequencing reaction that takes
place in Illumina and Illumina has a
full range of so this is basically your
Revolution where you have you know
depending on what is your requirement
you have various types of Illumina
sequences giving you a certain range of
high throughput depending on what is
your individual requirement right so
this is also democratized the sequencing
Revolution earlier sequencing used to be
only restricted to a few centers and you
have to send your samples now individual
Labs can have sequences of their choice
based on the requirements so this is
basically also democratization of the
sequencing reactions that were initially
not possible so that's the revolution so
here you are what Illumina uses as a
technique very similar to Sanger
sequencing except that in Sanger the
termination was permanent any Lumina the
termination is only uh temporary so what
they use is prior proprietary
nucleotides that have a virtual
Terminator moiety and a fluorescent
molecule attached to it as long as
virtual Terminator Monet is attached no
further extension happens that gives you
time to identify which nucleotide got
Incorporated once you have identified
the signal you cut off the social
Terminator moiety and now it is ready
for the incorporation of the next
nucleotide and I'll show you an
animation how this happens in the next
slide so the virtual Terminator
nucleotides are nucleotide analogs
contain a fluorescent dye and a
chemically cleavable group called
virtual Terminator group or virtual
Terminator moiety once Incorporated the
virtual term that an unlocks block
further incorporation until the water
Terminator moiety is chemically removed
therefore they are called virtual or
reversible Terminators because the
determination that happens happens is
reversible and contrast to standard the
virtual terminated label is removed
before the next cycle and you could do
it by chemical treatment so here you are
so here is your flow cell I am showing
you only two templates actually these
are multiple copies of the same
templates millions of copies will same
template in this location likewise
another template here and millions of
copies of this here which are generated
by British be there and now you start
with sequencing reaction you give all
four nucleotides together based on the
base complementarity rule individual
nucleotides will go and anneal and
because they are differentially labeled
they would give you a color and this
color is what you're detecting as your
signal right so here you have a thamine
incorporation thymine is blue so you
know on the template that will be an
added in likewise here there is an adult
incorporation adenine you have talked as
red so now you know that from the
template there is a thyroid and this is
your virtual Terminator moiety so before
moving on to the next cycle you need to
remove your virtual Terminator multi
once you remove that now you move on to
the next cycle again you have the
incorporation different with
complementality Rule and then again you
have the Terminator moiety so therefore
no further extension happens you can
read what is the floating is coming at
this position the flow cell what is the
fluorescence coming at this position in
the flow cell that allows you to
identify the nuclear Incorporated and
then again you can remove this and move
on to the next cycle so this is how it
happens this is how it works
so we're looking at two positions here
uh position one and position two and
we're looking at some six Cycles here
right so if you see here when you look
at this the first time you get the green
signals for both which means the citizen
got incorporated then the second time
you have adenine Incorporated in one and
you have a
citizen Incorporated again and the
second one and you can keep doing your
cycles and then you keep observing the
colors that are that are obtained at
individual positions and that finally
gives you the sequence for example here
of the second sequence every time it is
a green that is getting Incorporated
which means every time satisin gets
Incorporated between from the template
it could be a governance right and for
the top one you have for every cycle and
a critical are getting showing up which
means the reference into targets
Incorporated so finally you have a
sequence of cat p g t right so this is
how you take your cycles and if you see
the actual file of uh pass Q file of
Illumina sequence you will see this term
cycle Cycles means how many nucleotides
have been Incorporated right so as many
cycles you grow as many cycles will be
nucleotides would be incorporated
next we come to the Next Generation
frequencing techniques the third
generation here there is no Imaging and
because there is no Imaging these are
faster and much cheaper as compared to
the second generation
and here we have one that is Ion torrent
and this is an untoldrent machine here
and if you look at the basic idea of
iron torrent I showed you in the
incorporation of a nucleotide wire DNA
polymerase as the nucleotide gets
Incorporated you have the release of
hydrogen ion so instead of checking for
fluorescent this machine checks for
whether there has been a decrease in the
pH upon incorporation of one type of
nucleotide right so what you do here is
instead of giving all four nucleotides
together you give only one type of
nucleotide in one cycle and look at
positions where there is a decrease in
PH so that is the whole idea behind ion
torrent so here you are the flow cell is
flushed with single nucleotides at a
time the semiconductor chip records pH
changes upon incorporation or
complemented nucleotide by polymerase so
this is important that you give only one
type of nucleotide at a time you know
what you're giving so therefore if
you're giving adenine and you see at
certain positions there was a decrease
in PH you know that there was a thymine
on the temperate there right the chain
engine pH is proportional to the number
of nucleotides added and currently read
length is around 100 bases there have
been some improvement to this but not
Beyond let's say 150 basis for now
now we come to the new range of
sequences that have come up and these
are the long read sequences and one of
the primary ones here is what is known
as nanopore and the advantage is
nanoporous is it is small in size so it
can be used a point of care machine a
point of care device for a country like
India where the hospital setup is not
very expensive and patient has to go to
the hospital and and get checked these
devices can help the individuals go to
the patient instead of patient coming to
the doctor so basically these can serve
as what is known as the point of care
device right and that is the advantage
with nanopore uh devices here
essentially a nano scale whole the whole
may be biological solid state or hybrid
and the idea and here is an example of a
biological nanopore this is Alpha
hemolysis protein it is a heptameric
protein and you can see the 3D structure
here this is the tunnel this is actually
the nanopore and this is the side view
this is the front view this is the
tunnel through which you know you can
path your DNA if you wish to
is very simple the nanopore is placed
into an electric field and because it is
an electric field a basal current passes
through the nanopore now when you
introduce obstructions to the nanopore
or you allow certain molecules to pass
through the nanopore based on the shape
size and charge of the molecule you will
have characteristic fluctuations and
current and for us luckily what you have
is depending on both at adenine cytosine
one and thymine produce different
fluctuations and currents so that
fluctuation and current is
characteristic of the nucleotide that is
passing through that allows you to
translate into translated into a
sequence right and what is also
important here is that even a methylated
cytosine will produce a different
fluctuation as compared to a
non-muculated fatterson so therefore
here you can also study the epigenetic
state of your genome without going
through a very complicated process of
bicycle quite frequent things which is
done in Illinois process right so this
is where the advantages one you get long
reads second you can also use read get a
readout of your epigenetic state of the
genome without any special treatment of
the DNA right so when a single molecule
passes through the nanopore
characteristic disruptions occur in the
current flow based on the structural
feature can charge of the molecule
so this is what you do you basically use
a helicase so this is the technique
where we are not using DNA polymerase so
remember this so in nanopore you're not
interesting a complementary strand I'm
reading the nucleotides that they get
Incorporated what you simply do is
unwind a piece of DNA and force it
through a nanopore which is placed in an
electric field based on the fluctuations
in current as the nucleotide passes
through the sensitive position you will
have the the sequence translated into
attc right so this is what is nanopore
Oxford nanopore marketed by Oxford
nanopore time to sequence symmet genome
would be around you know roughly one
hour or something 15 to 20 minutes or if
it is absolutely perfect a size of the
sequencer of the pen drive and this is
scalable you could have multiple
nanopores put together into an assembly
cost of sequencing the human genome
would be around one thousand dollars
here right
so nanopore advantages direct RNA DNA
sequencing real time ultra long reads
I've already told you these are long
read sequences and you could get Ultra
long means around 50 KB of heat length
direct insulation call you don't have to
go through a buy sell pipe process for
sequencing scalable to to Portable to
our desktop and then of course point of
create Ryan device you could have a you
have a very small average preparation of
10 minutes and the High Fidelity this is
basically the advantages that you have
the other one that we have is what is
known as smrt single molecular time
sequencing this is still relying on DNA
polymerase and but what is important
here is that is only taking a single
molecule per sequencing so what are PCR
artifacts that that may happen during
your Illumina processing or or for that
matter and torrent it also uses PCR uh
these are ruled away right these are
these are outright rules now there are
two challenges to a single molecular
time sequencing one is the signal
intensity so because you have only one
molecule and you are incorporating a
fluorescent dntp the signal intensity
will be very low and how do you
compensate for that because that could
also be a artifact or or a complication
so for that what we do is very a simple
idea and let's say you have a 40 watt
bulb and you are placing it in your
drawing room which is the largest into
your kitchen and into your bathroom
which is the smallest so you know the
signal will be the intensity of light
will be the largest in your bathroom
because the area that it is covering is
very small so likewise what smrt does is
to basically immobilize a piece of DNA
polymerase and your DNA in a very small
volume which is known as 0 0 wave guide
right and we'll talk of it as we go
along so what you have is zero mode
waveguides so these are very small
spaces converted single DNA polymerase
is incorporated and it is and it is then
basically provided with the DNA template
that you want to sequence so therefore
the signal is still the intensity of is
still good enough to detect because the
volume of the space where you're doing
the reaction is very small then the
second important problem is polymerase
Fidelity so you know that polymerase is
not perfect so while you're sequencing
it may add a a non-complementary
nucleotide as well so if you have a
single real time single molecule then
once are in Mission Corporation happens
you would have this idea that you know
this this cannot be corrected so what
they do here is they circularize the
template that you want to sequence so
this is a sequence template that you
want to sequence you circularize it by
adding adapters at both ends and then
you sequence it multiple times like a
rolling Circle model so the polymerase
keeps sequencing it multiple times so
what happens is you will have the entire
sequence and in between you'll have your
adapters then you align your frequency
that you get so this is kind of a
concatener that you get and you align it
together and for each position you look
at the most frequent nucleotide that is
there and that is what is known as a
HiFi read you generate a consensus
sequence depending on what is the most
commonly occurring that is your greater
than 19 99 accuracy now so you have
overcome the two basic problems that are
there with single molecule sequencing
one was the signal intensity by creating
zero volts zero mode wave guides and
second you are looking at you know
circularizing your DNA and frequency
multiple times so if at all there is a
problem with respect to the Fidelity of
polymerase you are still looking at the
consensus sequence of the nucleotide
that appears most commonly at a given
position is what is your final sequence
so this kind of gives you high accuracy
so these are known as the high qualities
so this is your system here and then of
course this is a comparison of read lens
so you get on an average half the data
and read so greater than 30 KB some of
the reads 50 top five percent repeats
are greater than 50 KB and so on so
forth so therefore you know these are
long read length and that allows you to
basically assemble that you know uh more
correctly and a dino assembly of genomes
is possible Right
now we come to data analysis part and of
course data analysis can take a full
course of six months so what I'll try to
do is to give you a basic idea here
again not going to too many details but
to give you the basic steps in data
analysis first of course is the data
quality control and modification so you
first the data that comes is the raw
reads in the form of path Cube files and
then you have to check whether your
particle while the quality right or not
so normally there are certain programs
that are available for example you can
do a fast QC which is the most common
method of doing quality control fastqc
regenerate a lot of graphs that will
tell you whether your reads are good
quality or not it will give you a you
know the read quality at each position
then it will also give you the GC
content and count to Fourth and it will
also show you what a photograph would be
like so you can have your Corrections
based on that you could do certain
modifications the most common
modification is the removal of adapter
sequences which may be a contamination
the other thing is many a times as a
machine artifact with five Prime and
other primary frequences are not so
exact so those five or ten base pairs
can be taken away and that allows you
for a neat good quality data from there
on then once you have done this the next
step is to map the map the the sequence
to most commonly to a reference right or
in case you're doing a uh you know Deno
assembly then also you are basically
mapping them against each other to find
unique overlaps and you could align them
per reference most commonly if it is
Illumina you would be doing a alignment
to reference if it has long reads you
could do a genome assembly so you one
versus all versus all comparisons and
looking for unique collabs and then
beyond this point you depending on what
is the objective of the experiment to be
pipeline may be differently if you're
doing variation analysis you'll look for
variant calling so you'll follow the VCF
pathway if you are doing a transcriptome
so you would want to you know first
identify
exoner front boundaries assemble your
full transcript together and then
quantify how much of each each gene is
present if you want to if you're looking
at uh you know DNA protein interactions
so you would have your small fragments
of DNA to which your protein has bound
and you look for again quantify how much
of each type of frequences present if
you're looking for epigenetic States
again you will quantify for each region
how much of the cytosine of a given you
know for each position how much of a
given number of citizens are methylated
or not if you're looking at chromatin
States again you'll use a toxic so these
are the five major sequencing
applications that are the follow-up of
the initial sequencing that you give are
dnsic or NSA chipset VSA kind of plastic
and there are several other slider
modifications but these are the main
main ones main type of an also that you
do and because these sequencing data is
high throughput a manual analysis is not
possible so therefore you know the
importances of you know using the
programs that are available and because
programs can read only when the data is
present in a specific manner or format
so therefore NGS data analysis involves
a lot of format like to begin with we'll
discuss a few formats here the most
common format is basically your frequent
format so you have the path queue format
which is the standard format for
representing sequence data here so four
line format for sequencing data includes
quality scores
um that is why it is called Fast queue
because it also contains voltage course
I'll give you more detail because as we
move along alignment files time and Bam
format I will not talk of much details
of this and then you have annotation
which is gff3 and gtf format and then
you have intervals come out of the bed
format uh some of this we will not be
able to discuss today for lack of time
but of course we can go ahead and see
how much we can cover right the lecture
will extend a little maybe 10 or 15
minutes extra we'll see so here you are
this is a fast view format the password
format is the standard sequence format
that you have in
NGS in NGS data now if you look at this
this is one sequence is represented by
four lines the first is the identifier
Line This is a unique identifier for
each sequence so if there are 10 000
sequences in a pile each one will have a
unique identifier in the first line This
begins at the rate sign followed by some
encoding that gives it the uniqueness
then the second line is the sequence
plan the actual nucleotides identified
at each position then the third line is
begins with the plus sign and sometimes
it would be just having the plus and
nothing else and at other cases it would
have the identifier again following up
the plus sign the fourth line is the
quality Sports Line This is basically to
to basically you know indicate what is
the quality of the energy nucleotide
that you're calling at each position and
this is sqi encoded so you do not see
the actual numerical values but it can
be translated into metal values later on
for example here this
rectangular bracket or the the second
one basically represents the spread
quality of 29 so what is spread quality
we'll talk of that as we move along so
Fred is a program that assigns quality
scores to each nucleotide call in a
sequence credit scores are
logarithmically related to probability
of error so Q is the flight score it is
basically minus 10 block of v p right so
after the score of zero means the
probability of error is 1 right so this
is your zero our probability of error is
one applied score of 10 means
probability of error is 0.1 so this is
the probability of error T right a fret
score of 20 is probability of 0.01 error
upright score of 40 is probability of
0.001 so usually we have a range of 0 to
44 credit quality scores anything above
20 20 is acceptable anything below 20 is
not so acceptable right so this is what
is in in brief about the thread scores
so the first thing that you do once you
get your data is what is known as the
quality control and the most common
algorithm that we use for quality
control is the fast QC and fast you see
the top the first graph that you get in
first kiss is this so here you are this
is the quality Sports across all bases
this is basically what we'll see here
the quality score for the first position
they can push in third position for
position and then beyond a certain point
adjust the binning so for position 15 to
19 the cumulative quality score is now
being shown here right and this is the
range this is typically what is on a box
plot box in this cut plot you have
indications of the 25th and 75th
percentile and also the 10th and 98
percentile the green region is where it
is acceptable so anything above 28 to 40
is absolutely fine uh in fact anything
above 20 is also okay if you have most
of it in 40 a few and 28 is fine but
then if you have anything below between
0 to 20 then there is a problem if there
is a major part of your sequences here
then you'll have to you know trim to
that part unless your Source come up in
this range so after the first QC report
you do the trimming so as to ensure that
what you give what you give us data to
the next steps in the process are
absolutely confident data right
then the next step here once you've done
your trimming and everything is what is
known as the alignment and there are
several types of bananas that are
available you have a short little liners
and long data liners so you have shorted
a Learners like bow tie two
burrowsviller algorithm aligner a high
stat to mummer 4 star is for RNA
alignment Top Hat two is also four RNA
alignment fly is for Long Reach
sequencer DNA alignment so you depending
on what is the type of data that you
want and what is the type of platform
that we used you will have to select
which type of planner you're going to
use mostly all of them will give you uh
weirdly accurate results right then the
alignment format is also there this is
11 column string and you have several
inputs here so as to ensure that you
have you know you can go back and check
how good the quality of alignment have
to be right then we come to the
Revolution and we talk of milestones and
sequencing so if you see uh last to last
year nature came up where the special
issue February 2021 that's a natural
Milestone genome sequencing because this
was 20 years of the sequencing of the
human genome and you have the listings
here this is very short so let me just
give you a more uh more readable view so
1977 the first virus of sequence 1982
battery for Lambda was frequency the
first relieving organism equals 1995.
you can see there is a whole lot of Gap
until 2001 and since 2001 we have
started sequencing extensively and we
have sequenced literally everything that
we know is mostly sequenced now or or
sequencing today is now not a challenge
at all that is the basic Revolution that
we have today right while the first
human genome was sequenced in 10 years
at 3.2 billion dollars we are today
talking of sequencing a human genome at
hundred dollars and roughly half a day
or let's say you know less than half a
day so that is where our idea of
precision medicine takes Wings to half
Precision meditation as a general
Practice in medicine the first thing
that you require is that everybody needs
to get sequenced so therefore you know
that's the revolution that we're living
in today and of course for everything
today even for the coronavirus you know
that the confirmatory sequence test was
actually sequencing and you have some
narrow codes installed at airports when
at the peak of the corona phase right so
I'm sure you know that
plus you're following everyone
yes so
okay so I see the attendance has been uh
stable nobody has left so which is good
and encouraging I was expecting more
attendance though that is one thing that
that is a bit disappointing but it is
okay so here you are and we have come to
a point where where we can sequence uh
genome 10 times larger than the human
genome so for example here the Axolotl
genome and has been sequenced so just 10
times larger than the human genome right
so now sequencing is no more uh
sequencing genome is no more of a
challenge the challenge is analyzing the
data that comes after that because the
data that comes is huge and unless you
have certain you know programming skills
it will not be possible to analyze that
data so here you are broad applications
variant calling you could do a DNA SEC
and you could identify variants in an
individual genome and look for how these
variations impact as Wellness then you
could do an epigenomic study methylation
status citizens and CAG CAG and C H
context in plants so this is called
bicycle pipe sequencing and I've already
told you if you're using Illumina you'll
have to do a bicycle sequencing if
you're using nanopore or pack bio then
in that case and long red sequences the
readout for epigenetic state is also
automatic you don't have to go through a
special process then you have when I was
in Paris I was doing this VSC data
analysis uh roughly two years ago just
before the onset of of the pandemic in
fact I came to India after there was a
lockdown in France then you have the
transcriptome analysis rnsic data
analysis and then finally you have the
protein binding to DNA and that
announces another analysis I've already
also told you about ataxic analysis that
informs you about the chromatin state of
the DNA right
key features of NGS that make it so
important one is the scalability it is
massively parallel sequencing High
throughput parallel processing of
thousands of samples speed it is quick
whole genome in half a day now exome in
a day a what is exome exome is only the
express Express part of the genome so
we'll come to it what is an exhume and
why it is important then that's a high
resolution I've already told you this is
deep sequencing High coverage 100 to
150x very
um very routinely possible and single
base per resolution and then of course
because you use in second generation you
use small reads so mostly what you do is
a reference based assembly
coming to exome sequencing so I told you
even today uh a thousand dollar genome
sequencing is not possible uh it is
almost achievable now but not not so
much so while it is still exorbitantly
constant so uh
uh I mean it is it is very expensive so
what people do alternatively is to go
for what is known as Zone sequencing so
you know that you know only 1.5 percent
approximately I feel genome is actually
coding for genes and 85 percent of the
mutations that impact gene expression
are within these genic regions so what
you do is you are still getting 85
percent of your disease information by
just sequencing 1.5 percent of the
genome so therefore the cost of
sequencing goes dramatically down here
and you're still able to get almost 85
percent of your disease causing
information so therefore this is one
process that is preferred exome
sequencing as of today is very commonly
done right and uh so for example
sequencing you need to capture from your
fragmented Library you need to capture
only the DNA that corresponds to G's so
therefore you have special methods of
doing that we're not going to details
for lack of time but I'm sure you'll be
able to go through them then some of the
mendelian disease genes from exome or
genome sequencing data that have been
identified uh using second generation
sequencing this is the list given here
then of course you can do a targeted
panel Gene sequencing panel so instead
of letter you already know that these
are the significant mutations or
important sort of for a specific design
so you could create a panel of only
these mutations and do a direct
sequencing of only those parts and get
it on how you know how how what is the
probability of your patient or or your
subject getting that disease right so
this is what is mean of targeted Gene
sequencing panels focused panels contain
a select set of genes or Gene regions
that have known or suspected association
with the disease or to type under study
Gene panels can be purchased with
pre-selected content or custom designed
to include genomic regions of Interest
multiple genes can be assessed across
many samples and parallel saving time
and reducing the cost associated with
running multiple separated field and
what you also get here is a smaller and
more manageable data and more more
directed data instead of whole genome
where you get a lot of data but you're
not sure of what you're going to do with
that data so this one here based on the
knowledge base you could specifically
Target specific Noni so there's more
like a candidate Gene approach for
identifying whether the individual is
susceptible to a certain or what is the
what is the probability of his being
susceptible to a certain disease then
I'm sure you would know about
metagenomics so metagenomics is
basically studying bacterial populations
as a whole so earlier the conventional
method if you look at you took one water
sample let's say I wanted to know what
is the composition of my bacterial
population in the pond water sample so I
take the pond water sample I culture it
out first this is a mixed culture from
here I create pure culture to then
characterize the bacteria the problem
here is that the moment I go for
culturing I am losing out 99 of my
diversity straight away because
laboratory conditions and the media that
I use may not allow me to actually grow
all the organisms that are present in
this particular pond water sample the
alternate here is metagenomics where
this is basically an ngs-based
sequencing technique where you directly
extract the entire DNA sample do a whole
urine sequencing or a partial genome
sequencing in the sense that you could
only do a 16s for prokaryotes or
retainers for fungus and other
microorganisms and then do a molecular
characterization we match with the
database identify which type of
organisms are present in your
metagenomic sample so this basically
gives you a very you know
a very detailed idea of what could be
the possible components what would be
the possible species present and how
much of it is you know uh I mean also it
gives you an idea of some community
structure that is there
so we will not go to the details for now
but I'm sure you'll be able to see so
you could do a 16s rdna metagenomic
sequencing or you could do a whole
genome sequencing if you do whole genome
sequencing you would be able to identify
the bacteria until the screen level or
the subscreen level if you do the 16th
or DNA sequencing you would be identify
you would be able to identify the
bacterial population until the genus
level and very comprehensively so this
is basic idea of metagenomics there are
a whole lot of metagenomics projects
that are going on you have the human
microbiome project so one idea of the
wellness here is that also the the
bacterial population that is present in
your Elementary Canal could also decide
how a well and how physically fit you
are and there is also this idea of you
know micro microbiome implantation so
people are trying to identify what is
the composition of a microbiome in a
healthy individual versus the diseased
individual and whether a replacement of
this you know the healthy microbiome can
lead to rescue of the phenotype of or or
basically be you know the wellness of
the individual so these are some of the
projects that are going on you can have
a look there is also a project called
Earth microbiome project where you're
trying to catalog every single
microbiology is present on the earth and
from uh you know from all possible
niches
then we've already already talked about
largest genome ever sequence this is
Axolotl and this also gives us to the
and gets us to the idea of uh p-value
Paradox right C value Paradox I'm sure
you would have read it means basically
the idea is to you know uh
the C value Paradox essentially says
that you know the genome type does not
have any correlation with the complexity
of the organism so these are axolotal
salamanders aguilotal larvae
um these are these have DNA 10 times
larger than the human genome
so this is one review you can go through
uh and that is where I picked up the
title from also I added my part from
Evolution to Revolution and that makes
it very cheesy and and very you know
striking so DNA sequencing at 40 past
movement in future is one review that
you you may refer to I'm also writing
one review on genetic techniques that
would come up in the next few months you
can also have a reference here then as I
referred we are now only in 2022 April
that we have been able to sequence the
human genome absolutely completely from
one from position one to position last
on the chromosome so telomere to
telomere assembly this is called and
this is done by in 2019 Karen Mega and
Adam Philippi organized assembly
Consortium to fill the missing pieces in
the human genome and when you dip this
what is the extra amount of sequence you
got you added nearly 200 million base
pairs of Novel DNA sequence including 99
genes likely to code for protein such
not known till date and nearly 2000
candidate genes that need further study
for and further curation to to basically
identify whether they're actually genes
or not it also corrects thousands of
structural errors in the current
reference sequence the grtr38 references
sampling so this is as late as April 2
2022 and those who want to get into
research must keep reading papers right
that is important again this is the
the assembly here this is called T2 chm
13 version 2.0 on ncbi you can have a
look at this right and then of course
maybe for lack of time I'll skip this
part except that I'll give you an idea
of what this means so basic idea is if
you look at the you know
if you look at the conventional method
of giving the medicine the idea is that
irrespective of whatever the genotype
individual has you give the same amount
of medicine to everyone one goes in the
morning one goes in the afternoon one
goes in the evening now based on the
mutations that the person carries uh the
same amount of dose may be effective in
summer noodles and maybe actually toxic
to other individuals so therefore uh in
personalized medicine one idea is also
is to look at the genome and based on
the variation that the individual is
carrying you need to modulate the dosage
that is given to the individual right
and here is the reference you can go
back and look at the reference of this
paper and this is the difference here
and for lack of time I'm not covering
this for now but you can always go back
and check what lies ahead we are moving
into the era of pan genome so this would
be basically now that multiple
individuals have sequenced in multiple
countries and there is a whole lot of
frequency information available the
reference human genome will be replaced
by watercolon FB pan genome pan genome
would be a combination of multiple
sequences put together and multiple very
variation information put together and
also the impact of those durations in
this local sub population so that is
where we are heading and that should
basically be the beginning point now for
our next series of precision medicine
and other experiments
the desired skill set so now that here
we have come to the last let me just
give you the desired tool set and use
data type is typically big data and
requires computational data analytics
skills you need to know one programming
language python is preferred now because
python is the base now you should also
have good statistical knowledge so you
must be you should know RR is free
Matlab State biostatistics is because
you have a huge data you use statistics
every step to to show that what you're
taking forward is actually good quality
then you could use some command line you
know some scripting like awk some tools
Picard santus bedrooms BestMark Etc you
could also be familiar with Galaxy which
is an online
integrated development environment for
induced analysis and then familiar with
Linux environment would help so this is
where we end if you want to go into some
more details on my YouTube channel you
could go to my YouTube channel my
YouTube channel the same name Dr weapons
biotech and Mathematics classroom and
there is a whole lot of you know talks
there you can have a look so for example
here there are more than six playlists
now you have a playlist on recommended
DNA technology and there is a playlist
on R there is a playlist on tools and
techniques in biotechnology introductory
by mathematics and so on so forth and go
go home and have a look I'm sure you
would find it useful there is also a a
playlist on python so I'm also teaching
python we've begun with simple steps and
today I think by tonight I will be 20
000 views by tonight so the channel is
doing well and you can have a look right
so on that note I'll close the channel
has the same name Dr weapons biotech and
bioinformatics classroom right so you
can go have explore the channel if you
like you can like you can subscribe you
can share recommend your friends and so
on so forth right so we stop here I see
some chat messages so let me see thank
you so much right marvelous to everyone
okay and then sir don't you think there
would be any error in Human Genome
Project during the third assembly stage
as the third billions yes absolutely so
that is why we are moving to the pan
genomic State and I've already told you
that with the telomere to telomere
assembly we have you know identified
certain errors and structural alert
motto and that have been corrected so
kruti I think that is the answer to your
question
uh okay there's only one question
anybody else who wants to ask a question
you have another two minutes for that
right uh else will close the session
any other question class
so uh
first of all I would like to thank you
sir so much for such an enriching talk I
also got to learn so much about NGS
today and I had heard about
um a few things but you know you
explained it in such a great manner
thank you so much sir and about
participation also I would like to say
that you know sometimes the time zone
becomes an issue because I had some
participants join at around 6 50. but
then they had to go because the session
was late but we have people that ask us
for the recording and we also share it
over our YouTube where we have like
around 12K um subscribers so yeah so
thank you so much sir and I had a few
questions here
oh yes yeah so I also had a few uh
questions that came up to me in the
personal uh message you can firstly go
through marvelous question and then I
can um like quickly so marvelous asks
what are the prerequisites to get into
meta genomics for someone with no
background in comics so the prerequisite
to get into metagenomics would be you
know to uh first understand the basic
concepts of genomics right uh also
understand what does this 16 srna and
how is it used as a marker and how you
can use the full volume sequencing and
plus also you know a programming
background would help so as I said
prerequisites would include a bit of
knowledge of python a bit of knowledge
of R and if that is not possible then
definitely you have to be conversant
with Galaxy whatever now which are the
workflow pipelines for non-programmers
but it is always good to know
programming that would that would be
basically this
ah no problem Nokia no problem so maybe
if it is recorded you can have
ah thank you kriti thank you so much
right thank you so much I would like to
ask you um two questions quickly uh
which was sent to me so one of it was
that DNA sequencing has transformed the
field of forensic science in your
perspective have we reached the maximum
potential of this technology or where do
you see the future of DNA sequencing
headed in forensic science
okay so as you know in forensic science
up till now the basic gold standard was
DNA fingerprinting right so you looked
at specific regions in the vntrs and
other regions where you could develop a
fingerprint and that could basically
help you implicate you know who is the
perpetrator of the crime or let's say
species identification so you could do a
p450 amplification identify up to the
species level let's say you have
confiscated from Bones and they want to
know if this bone is coming from human
or from you know animal so which is the
most common type of cases that you
generally get so that could be done and
now of course everything is going
through this sequencing so I already
told you that the in the in the initial
part that there is a new thing now that
uh sequence of the new microscope so
once you sequence something you are
absolutely sure that there is no iota of
of doubt about you know that uh what is
the what is the belonging of the
sequence uh two I mean who which is
species or which individual does it to
there is very little doubt in that so I
think that will be the ultimate of DNA
uh N4 n6 there's to do DNA sequencing
and then
unambiguously identify whatever your
sample does or whatever your case is so
I guess yes we are very good and the
plummeting cost of sequencing so
initially the why we used to go for
southern hybridization or those kind of
tests of PCR amplification test was
because those were cheaper than
sequencing now that the sequencing cost
is coming down and it is uh absolute
analogous you know explanation and even
when you did PCR amplification for DNA
fingerprinting and then if it as a
confirmation you also did sequencing so
therefore now uh sequencing could be a
straight away first answer right so that
is I I would suggest that you know
everything is now boiling down to
sequencing and the cost that has come
down I'm sure you know of the law where
you know it is said that the cost of
transistors that come down to half and
and the capacity would go by double and
moves from all that is frequencing
co-ops have beaten Moore's law by by
Miles so therefore it becomes very
important and how can you assist someone
who wants to build up skills and
Mathematics well assisting someone and
building bioinformatics you can check my
YouTube blogs there and there is one
that is talking about introduction to
bank schematics one thing so basic
bioinformatics is where this mathematics
that we do uh some of the basic analysis
you can do web-based
then also I have a channel on I have a
playlist on our programming and I have a
playlist on Python Programming which is
mostly for buying competitions uh with
some basic data analysis so you could go
there and check that I hope that will be
helpful and then in case you have some
individual questions you can always come
back to me and ask me right I'm
available 24 7. so no time zone issues
here right so you can always come back
my email is given you can check my email
and get back to me at any point of time
right recently I had given a talk in
Africa that was where the one group
there and I had a few attendants there
right you're most welcome Eric my
banking right and everybody else
that if you have any internship
opportunities in your working field
and not in our University as of now but
uh we'll see if it is available it will
be advertised I'm very active on social
media on LinkedIn other things are you
she knows right so yes so if there is
the
so okay so I'll give you the mail here
it is the PIN
dot thing
dot p u
H
right and you could go to Google and
type within a classroom right you could
type within C classroom it will take you
to my website you will have my
information there as a v i p i n weapons
e c l a s is that will take you to my
website also it will give you the idea
of where my YouTube channel is and just
type on Google and the first it would be
my website you can just check that
so any other questions
so just the last one uh are there any
freely available NGS analysis tools or
softwares
yes yes everything is freely available
NGS announcers was very democratized
right so the tools are freely available
so like first QC just type on Google and
you'll be able to download it right and
it is it is a Linux based uh unless
you're doing web-based it uh you will
have to be into Linux environment
everything is really available there is
nothing that is you know paid for more
and and even if there are some paid
softwares there is always a counterpart
uh where which is reliable for example
again like R and Matlab so Matlab can
also help you do statistical analysis
like R but Matlab is paid but r as uh as
a framework is freely available right
and then everything is available also on
Galaxy and not one tools there are
multiple tools that are available all
you need to do is to explore a bit and
you will be able to you know find a tool
that suits your requirement for example
if it's if you remember I showed you bow
tie I showed you red hat I showed you
Bob had not read at the top hat I showed
you fly so these are all aligners that
are available freely
so most of the data analytics that you
do with NGS is freely available should
not be a problem with that
all right thank you so much sir once
again for joining with us today and for
such such an enriching talk it was
really great to have you and
also send me to send me the recording
huh yes I'll show you send you the
recording and so we will also like for
the participants because when we shared
about your session I had so many emails
and messages regarding it so we will be
sharing it with them also if they'll be
asking about the session in case they've
missed it and they have a problem yes
all right sir thank you so much
yeah you're welcome Ash